this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by brilliant
the problem-solving website that teaches
you to think like an engineer
installed global capacity of solar cells
has increased
year on year for the past decade fueled
by the plummeting prices
and rising efficiency of solar cells
forcing fossil fuel producers out of the
market
through technological advance at the end
of 2019
the total installed capacity of
photovoltaic cells
exceeded 630 000 megawatts
an astounding figure that is going to
continue to rise in the coming decades
however in the 40 years we've been using
solar cells
there has been a mystery flaw that has
been sapping away
potential electricity from the
photovoltaic cells
upon testing in the laboratory newly
manufactured solar cells
display an efficiency of about twenty
percent
meaning they can convert twenty percent
of the incoming energy
from sunlight into electric current
however
within hours of operation that
efficiency would drop to eighteen
a 10 drop in total electric generation
losing 10 of 630 000 megawatts of power
is no small problem that's equivalent to
about 30
nuclear power plants worth of power
capacity if the solar panels could
operate
all day which they can't but you get the
point
there's a lot of potential electricity
being lost
it's no wonder that scientists and
engineers have been hunting down the
cause of this problem
termed light-induced degradation for 40
years
and last year we may have finally
cracked the problem and found the cause
behind
this mysterious loss in power to
understand it
we first have to understand how
photovoltaic cells work
photovoltaic cells use the photovoltaic
effect
to generate a current an effect where
photons of a particular threshold
frequency
striking a material can cause electrons
to gain enough energy
to free them from their atomic orbits
and move freely
in the material this is best achieved
with semiconductors
whose unique properties lying between
conductors and insulators
allows them to most easily elevate
electrons from atomic orbit
to moving freely among their atoms some
of the first solar cells were created
with selenium
like this one created by charles fritz
sitting atop a new york roof
in 1884 a revolutionary device that
produced a consistent current of
electricity
but it was achieving an efficiency of
just one percent
converting one percent of the energy
striking it in the form of light
into electricity this in combination
with the high cost of selenium
made it an unviable source of
electricity
to succeed these devices needed to
compete with fossil fuel power sources
before the photovoltaic effect could
power the world
scientists and engineers would need to
figure out
how to increase that efficiency
percentage and to do it
with cheaper materials enter silicon
a common semiconductor material that has
formed the bedrock of the electronic age
this is going to be our starting
material for our solar cell
let's build the solar cell from scratch
and see how
efficiencies were gradually increased
over time
let's first look at what happens when
light interacts with the pure silicon
crystal
like this incoming light can do one of
three things
it can be reflected absorbed or simply
pass right through it
if light is reflected or passes through
it cannot produce the photovoltaic
effect
step one to improving our efficiency is
to minimize the amount of light
that gets reflected off the material
this is wasted energy that affects our
efficiency level
in fact 30 percent of light that strikes
untreated silicon is reflected so
before we even start our maximum
efficiency drops to 70
for this reason silicon is often treated
with a layer of silicon monoxide which
can reduce the light reflected
to just 10 percent while a second layer
with a secondary material
like titanium dioxide can reduce it as
low
as 3 percent texturing the surface of
the material can further increase the
probability of light being absorbed
if it is textured like this light that
is initially reflected
has another chance to strike the
material and be absorbed
only light that is absorbed can
potentially cause the photovoltaic
effect
but not all light will we need photons
above a threshold energy to
increase an electron's energy enough to
allow it to move freely in the material
a photons energy is defined by
multiplying planck's constant
by its frequency silicon requires
photons with 1.1
electron volts to produce the
photovoltaic effect
which corresponds to a wavelength of
1110 nanometers
this lies around here in the light
spectrum and any lower energy from here
down
cannot produce the photovoltaic effect
this light will simply cause the atom to
vibrate and create heat
this graph shows the total solar energy
being emitted by the sun
however a good deal of this does not
reach the earth's surface
as it is absorbed by the atmosphere this
is a more realistic graph
about four percent of the energy
reaching earth's surface
is in ultraviolet as the sun emits
relatively little
ultraviolet photons 44 percent is in the
visible spectrum
and 52 is in the infrared spectrum
this may sound surprising as infrared is
lower energy
but it covers a wider range of the
spectrum and thus accounts
for more energy because silicon cannot
make use of light with a wavelength
greater than 1110 nanometers everything
from here up
is energy we cannot convert into
electricity
this represents about 19 of the total
energy
reaching earth another thing to note is
that light with higher energy
does not release more electrons it
simply produces
higher energy electrons blue light has
roughly twice the energy of red light
but the electrons that blue light
releases simply lose their extra energy
in the form of heat
producing no extra electricity this
energy loss results in about 33 percent
of sunlight's energy being lost
so these spectrum losses alone cause a
52
loss in efficiency this is a lot of
energy to lose
but silicon sits near the ideal
threshold frequency that balances
these two energy losses capturing enough
of the lower energy wavelengths
while not losing too much efficiency as
the result of the material heating up
this is such a large loss in power that
in some climates
active cooling which takes some of the
electricity the panels create
to cool the panels actually results in
more electricity being generated
the reason solar panels lose efficiency
as they get hotter
is quite complicated and outside the
scope of this video
but for now all you need to know is that
silicon balances
these factors best for terrestrial
purposes
on to the next problem knocking an
electron free
by itself does not create an electrical
current in our circuit
it just frees an electron to move freely
about the material
to create a useful current we have to
force this electron around an external
circuit
where it can do work freeing electron
also creates a positively charged hole
in its place that is also free to move
about the material
if an electron meets a hole it simply
fills it and our energy is wasted
the next trick to maximize efficiency is
to limit the chances electrons have
to fill these holes and to force them
into our circuit
as quickly as possible to do this we
used the unique properties of silicon
silicon has four electrons in its outer
shell and thus
readily forms a crystal structure with
four neighboring atoms
using covalent bonds a bond where
neighboring atoms share an electron pair
we can manipulate this behavior and
tailor the crystal's material properties
by adding impurities called dopants
say we add boron atoms to the silicon
crystal wafer
these boron atoms have three electrons
available for bonding
with the silicon crystal but silicon
wants four
so this creates a hole in the crystal
that wants to be filled
with an electron we call this a p-type
as it has positive charge carriers now
let's say we create another wafer of
silicon
but this time we add atoms with five
electrons available for bonding
like phosphorus again the phosphorus
bonds with the silicon
but this time we have an extra electron
that can float freely about the material
we call this an n-type because it has
negative charge carriers
now let's sandwich these two materials
together and see what happens
the positive holes and negative
electrons migrate towards each other
the electrons will jump into the p-type
and the holes jump into the n-type
this causes an imbalance of charge
because now the p-type has more negative
charges and the n-type
has more positive charges we have just
formed an electromagnetic valve
that allows electrons to pass in one
direction let's see how this works
suppose a photon with sufficient energy
enters the p-type side
of the solar cell and knocks an electron
free
the electron starts bouncing around the
material and one of two things can
happen
it can recombine with a hole resulting
in no current
or it can come into the electromagnetic
field
at the junction of the materials here
the electromagnetic field
actually accelerates the electron across
the junction
into the n-type side where there are
very few holes for it to fill
and to boot the junction's
electromagnetic field
actually prevents the electron from
passing back to the other side
a similar thing happens on the n-type
side where holes are selectively
transported
across the junction before they can
recombine
this means one side of the junction
becomes negatively charged
while the other side becomes positively
charged we have created a potential
difference
or in other words a voltage if we add
some metal contacts and an external load
circuit
these electrons will pass along the
circuit to recombine with the holes
on the other side we've just created a
solar cell
you may notice a problem here though by
adding metal contacts to the upper
surface of the solar cell we've just
blocked light from entering the cell
and thus reduced its efficiency this is
yet another problem
engineers have had to think carefully
about in their quest
to optimize solar cell efficiency over
the years
engineers have optimized both the shape
and manufacturing techniques
to minimize the area covered by the
metal electrodes
while also minimizing the resistance the
electrons will face in
entering the external circuit one
research paper used topology
optimization
to design these electric contacts
topology optimization
uses algorithms to optimize the design
of objects
using constraints the engineer inputs
using this method for the electric
contacts produce something remarkably
like the vasculature of a leaf
that shouldn't really surprise you
vasculature on a leaf
does not perform photosynthesis it
instead brings the water that is
essential for
photosynthesis to the leaf and extracts
the useful products
serving a similar purpose as our
electric currents
so of course plants have developed the
perfect shape
to optimize the energy they can absorb
from the sun
plants have had millions of years to
evolve this shape
however most solar cells use a simple
grid shape
as it is cheaper to manufacture this
typically results in an efficiency loss
of about
eight percent all told these effects
result
in a typical modern solar cell having a
laboratory tested efficiency of 20
so what was happening to cause that drop
to 18
after a couple of hours of operation
this problem was the focus of hundreds
of scientific papers
and many found clues to the problem
manny noted that the efficiency drop was
correlated
to the concentration of boron and oxygen
in the silicon
and noted that the drop did not occur
when boron was substituted
with gallium thus it was known a boron
oxygen defect was causing the issue
others found that the defects could be
reversed by heating the silicon
in the dark at 200 degrees for 30
minutes
but it would return once again upon
exposure to the light
efforts in reducing the problem have
primarily focused on reducing the
concentration of oxygen impurities
in the silicon wafers which occur as a
result of the silicon manufacturing
technique
that is the source of 95 of silicon
solar cells
these manufacturing techniques are still
a point of research
and the engineers and scientists were
working blindly
little was known about the actual defect
creation process
and how exactly it was causing such a
large drop in efficiencies
leaving engineers with less information
to solve the problem with
this paper used a special imaging
technique and observed
these boron oxygen molecules converting
into something the paper refers to
as shallow acceptors when exposed to
light
in essence they observe the defects
transforming into little electron
traps that acted as recombination sites
and thus reduced the time and
probability of electrons
entering the circuit to do work with
this knowledge
engineers can now develop better
techniques for preventing this
phenomenon
and hopefully increase our renewable
energy capacity
in the coming years it's easy to think
that technology has reached a point of
being so advanced
that knowing where things can be
improved is practically impossible
for the average person but that simply
isn't true
a little bit of research into any area
will reveal
countless problems humans are still
grappling with fixing
when i started researching this video i
knew little about solar panels
beyond the basics in order to make this
video
i took a week to deep dive into some
college textbooks using my knowledge
of material science and electronics to
guide my research
but i had some gaps in understanding
that the college textbooks just assumed
i had pre-existing knowledge of
terms like band gap and fermi levels
kept appearing and without understanding
these terms
i couldn't make complete sense of the
explanations
these were like canyons in my journey
for knowledge i couldn't advance until i
filled them in
so halfway through the research in
writing process
i decided to stop what i was doing i
changed my tactics
and i decided to take the brilliant
course on solar energy
because i knew brilliant would guide me
through the very basics of the subject
right through to the more complicated
concepts it worked a treat
all the little gaps in my understanding
were filled in and i could now read
scientific papers
and college textbooks without feeling
like i was reading a foreign language
this is the magic of brilliant
brilliance courses are curated
incredibly well
and allow you to go from knowing nothing
to being an expert
this is just one of many courses on
brilliant brilliant thought-provoking
math
science and computer science courses
help guide you to mastery by taking
complex concepts and breaking them up
into bite-sized
understandable chunks you'll start by
having fun with their interactive
explorations
and over time you'll be amazed at what
you can accomplish
if you are naturally curious want to
build problem solving skills
want to develop confidence in your
analytical abilities
or like me find yourself struggling to
paris the language of advanced college
textbooks
because you are missing some fundamental
knowledge then get brilliant premium to
learn something new
every day as always thanks for watching
and thank you to all my patreon
supporters
if you'd like to see more from me the
links to my twitter instagram discord
server and subreddit are below
you